дорогі друзі Доброго дня Доброго
здоров'я Слава Україні Сьогодні ми
починаємо роботу нашої секції в межах
роботи серпневої конференції яка у нас є
основою для початку нового року зазвичай
наша Серпнева конференція асоціюється зі
святом зі святом підготовки до
навчального року в цьому році ми маємо
особливі умови і ми маємо проводити нашу
серпневу конференцію В умовах воєнного
стану бо зайвих емоцій та зосереджень
Дозвольте мені представити вам всіх
учасників
сьогоднішньої конференції це Мене звуть
Вітренко Андрій Я перший заступник
міністра освіти і науки України
Юлія Миколаївна Гришина народний депутат
голова під комітету з питань вищої
освіти Вітаю всіх
Максим Георгійович Луцький ректор
національного авіаційного університету
Доброго дня Андрій Петрович Бутенко
Голова Національного агентства
забезпечення якості вищої освіти Доброго
дня колеги
і курс Віктор Петрович голова Товариства
Динамо віце-президент олімпійського
комітету
тож Дозвольте розпочати сьогоднішню нашу
панель яка має назву виклики та
перспективи
вищої освіти в умовах воєнного стану
Як ви чудово знаєте вища освіта з 24
лютого цього року як і вся країна
функціонує в дуже екстремальних умовах і
ці умови
Скажімо так вимагають від нас
зосередитися на тих завданнях що мають
які ми отримали в спадок вони потребують
свого логічного завершення і поєднати їх
з актуальними завданнями які спричинені
війною і тим завданням які визначать
перспективу
функціонування системи вищої освіти
не втрачає сьогодні актуальності
завдання визначено стратегією розвитку
вищої освіти яке була схвалена яка була
схвалена урядом України напередодні
війни але ж для примноження потенціалу
вищої освіти і національної системи її
Нам необхідно забезпечити інноваційний
характер її розвитку Що ж ми маємо
зробити ми маємо зробити управління в
системі вищої освіти ефективним а вищу
освіту соціальна відповідальність
сформувати довіру громадян держави та
бізнесу до освітнього наукової та
інноваційної діяльності закладів вищої
освіти забезпечити належну якість
освітньої наукової діяльності
зробити наші заклади вищої освіти
України привабливими для навчання та
академічної кар'єри забезпечити
інтернаціоналізацію вищої освіти
для досягнення визначених цілей
необхідно зробити певні кроки Які би ми
визначили як наступні це вдосконалення
системи управління вищої освіти
гаманізація структури вищої освіти
України відповідно до зобов'язань які
тої честі які ми отримали як кандидат на
вступ до
Євросоюзу забезпечити розбудову
доступної інфраструктури закладів вищої
освіти та вдосконалити системи її
фінансування
розширити діяльність
закладів вищої освіти шляхом надання
освітніх послуг у сфері освіти в
дорослих та інноваційній сфері розширити
зв’язки між наукою освітою та реальним
сектором економіки забезпечити
інтеграцію до освітнього наукового
простору створити підґрунтя для
подальшої трансформації вищої освіти і
створити підґрунтя для того щоб
Національна система вищої освіти України
зайняла чильне місце в системі
освіти Європейського Союзу
досягнення зазначених цілей дозволить
нам вирішити наступні проблеми зокрема
це неефективне управління та
використання ресурсів брак відкритості
закладів вищої освіти в низку
спроможність продукувати корисну
інтелектуальну продукцію та принципово
приділяти протидіяти проявам корупції та
академічної доброчесності дозволить
забезпечити рівень доступності вищої
освіти а також вирішити проблематику яка
дуже
важлива для всіх наших колег
науково-педагогічних працівників це
неконкурентна заробітна плата та умови
праці працівників
в цілому Система вищої освіти України
продемонстрували великий адаптивний
потенціал під час вимушеного переходу на
дистанційні інноваційні технології
навчання Разом з тим обмежені можливості
які інфраструктури багатьох закладів
освіти та незадовільний рівень цифрової
компетентності наукових
науково-педагогічних та педагогічних
працівників не дозволило забезпечити
освітній процес вимогу дистанційного
навчання на достатньому рівні його
якості тому необхідно прискорити
розвиток ефективних цифрових освітніх
екосистем розвиток цифрових умінь
навичок компетентності для цифрової
трансформації це дуже важливе завдання
вищої освіти вже сьогодні
окремо хочу згадати про те що надання
Європейської Ради України статусу
кандидата на вступ до ЄС передбачає
всеохоплюючу трансформацію всіх сфер
суспільного життя в короткостроковій
перспективі тому в контексті інтеграції
до Європейського Союзу актуальності
набувають наступні напрями це
реформування та модернізація мережі
вищої освіти сприяння зближенню у сфері
вищої освіти в рамках Болонського
процесу
підвищення якості та важливості і
значення вищої освіти в українському
суспільстві розширення можливостей
закладів вищої освіти в сфері їх
управлінського управлінського автономії
активізація мобільності студентів
наукових науково-педагогічних та
педагогічних працівників
Разом з тим сьогодні першочергові
відповіді потребують ті питання які були
поставлені нам воєнним станом та
безглуздою агресією Російської Федерації
в Україні важливим є питання відновлення
і розвитку інфраструктури закладів вищої
освіти що зазнали руйнувань та
пошкоджень внаслідок збройної агресії не
менше актуальним є питання відновлення і
розвитку кадрового потенціалу адже
велика кількість наших колег
конкурентознатним наукових та
науково-педагогічних працівників на жаль
вимушені були
покинути Україну та виїхати за кордон
і деякі з них На жаль відповідно до
проведених нами досліджень втратили
зв'язок зі своїми закладами вищої освіти
функціонування системи вищої освіти в
умовах обмеженого фінансування через
зменшення обсягів бюджетного
фінансування у зв'язку з організацією
економіки
це також один з викликів який нам
представив воєнний стан окремо хочу
згадати що необхідно налагодити
ефективну роботу з переміщеним закладами
вищої освіти та надавати їм всебічну
підтримку в їх освітні та Науковій
діяльності
Шановні колеги
найголовнішим І найважливіше на сьогодні
завдання є забезпечення безпеки
освітнього процесу в новому навчальному
році з урахуванням всіх можливих загроз
які спричинені воєнним станом Звертаю
увагу що Міністерство освіти і науки
України як центральної і головний орган
виконавчої влади в сфері освіти і науки
рекомендувала впровадити освітній процес
закладом вищої фахового передвищої
освіти максимально наближено до
традиційного формату але з урахуванням
обмежень воєнного часу та забезпечення
безпеки всіх учасників освітнього
процесу
передбачаємо що поряд з традиційним
офлайн навчанням значна доля освітнього
процесу буде припадати на змішаний
формат тобто очний з використанням
дистанційних методів навчання в окремих
випадках ми рекомендуємо дистанційний
формат але все ж це ви знаєте тому що ми
свої рекомендації і ви їм чудово
розслідуєте нагадаю що відповідно до
спеціальних законів заклади вищої
фахової передвищої освіти є автонованими
та самоврядними Тому рішення щодо
початку навчального процесу приймає
кожен заклад освіти самостійно Разом з
тим
керівник кожного закладу вищої освіти
приймаючи дане рішення має враховувати
наступне
впровадження освітнього процесу заочно
формує навчання у приміщеннях закладу
освіти в традиційному або змішаному
форматі погоджуються з обласними
Київської міської військової
адміністрації
проведення освітнього процесу
традиційному форматі А також видів
навчальних занять або виконання окремих
освітніх компонентів які не можуть бути
ефективно та якісно проведені в
дистанційного форматі або з міркувань
Безпеки може бути організовано на базі
інших закладів освіти в тому числі в
інших регіонах за попередньою
Міністерство готове надати підтримку для
організації такого формату освітнього
процесу зокрема переміщеним закладом
вищої освіти
наступне впровадження освітнього процесу
в традиційному або змішаному форматах
приміщеннях закладів освіти або його
окремим корпусі має здійснюватися в
межах розрахункової місткості захисних
споруд які можуть бути використані для
укриття учасників освітнього процесу в
разі надходження сигналу повітряна
тривога або в разі надходження інших
відповідних сигналів оповіщення також
повинна враховуватися місткість споруд
цивільного захисту які можуть бути
використані мешканцями гуртожитків які
фактично будуть переживати
окремо нагадаю що має забезпечуватися
безумовне переривання освітнього процесу
в приміщенні закладу освіти у разі
надходження сигналу повітряна тривога
або інших відповідних сигналів
оповіщення
Шановні колеги Сьогодні ми хочемо з вами
обговорити згадані питання для
усвідомлення відповідальності за безпеку
учасників освітнього процесу
забезпечення успішності виконання
запланованих завдань і пошуку ефективних
шляхів досягнення поставлених цілей
друзі Я хотів би вам нагадати що ви
можете задавати нам питання Я буду дуже
просити питання свої спрямовувати в
загальний чат
Скажімо так Ви маєте представитись Хто
ви є Які заклад освіти представляєте і
потім написати своє питання Якщо у нас
вистачить часу ми будемо надавати
відповідь онлайн якщо з часом не
вистачить ми зберемо всі ваші питання та
обов'язково їх висвітлимо безпосередньо
в рекомендаційному Листі Міністерства
освіти і науки якими будемо
розсилати всім закладам освіти за
результатом ми роботи сьогоднішньої наші
серпневої конференції Дякую вам всім за
увагу Слава Україні і передаю слово Юлії
миколаївні
Олександр
чу колеги я вітаю всіх всю ту величезну
кількість освітян і не тільки освітян
які зараз долучилися до нашої
традиційної
стравневої конференції і шостий місяць в
Україні триває війна Не дивлячись на це
вся система освіти працює і я ще раз
хочу відзначити я скрізь це відзначаю що
не було жодного дня коли в система
освіти
припинила свою роботу з того моменту як
розпочалася війна тому я дякую кожному
сміттям я дякую всім тут присутнім я
дякую всій системі освіти кожному
освітян який працював на нашому
освітянському фронті і Загалом ми
сьогодні маємо такі результати що
нас активно зараз триває вступна
кампанія і ми
реагуємо всі разом всі гілки влади на
сьогодні абсолютно об'єднані ми відклали
всі політичні питання вони відклали всі
проблеми які раніше нас дуже хвилювали
зараз на Зовсім інше життя ми всі
об'єднані законодавча влада виконавча
влада місцева Влада ми всі працюємо
кожного дня разом і це величезна
цінність що система освіти змогла так
об'єднатися і зараз в умовах війни
підставляємо плече один одному і
працюємо всі разом і маємо наслідки що
на сьогодні і Протягом всієї системи
всієї війни система освіти працювала
працює зараз і буде працювати надалі
якщо можна включити презентацію як
коротко пройдуся по
наших основних моментах На що б я хотіла
зараз звернути увагу перше у мене тема
моїй доповіді виклики та перспективи В
умовах воєнного стану я зверну Вашу
увагу на ті основні моменти про які
хотіла сьогодні
окремо на них наголосити Отже які
проблеми виникли у нас одразу в перші
дні і з чим нам одразу
Ми були вимушені працювати І що я хочу
звернути увагу що Нам вдалося всім разом
з вами перше питання проблема яке в нас
виникла це масло в перші дні в війні
наші
діти школярі студенти викладачі
масово змінювали місце перебування і
звичайно в нас виникла проблема Коли нам
потрібно було продовжувати навчальний
процес в таких умовах Я хочу сказати що
активно працювало Міністерство активно
активно працювали університети тим чином
те що ми забезпечили можливість
переміщатися нашим студентам і
долучатися до навчального процесу в
інших університетах це робилося дуже
швидко робилося
дуже в дружній обстановці ми дійсно
спостерігали я сама їздила по багатьох
регіонах і спостерігала як дружню
зустрічали університети студентів і
викладачів з зони де ведуться активні
бойові дії долучали і до навчального
процесу
не піднімалися жодні там питання
проблеми Всі казали про те що про
головне будемо обговорювати потім зараз
ми їх вирішуємо Це є дуже дякую
всім університетам Які відкрили свої
двері і підтримали наших студентів і які
тимчасово були вимушені змінювати місце
навчання і проживання і наших викладачів
і звичайно ми одразу зрозуміли що нам
потрібно змінювати систему вступу до
закладів вищої освіти Оскільки ми з
перших днів війни почали розуміти що ми
не зможемо
використати ту зрозумілу для нас систему
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання В
умовах воєнного стану
які рішення цих проблем ми прийняли
одразу ж
на перших етапах Отже перше Верховна
Рада України
в такому достатньо шлунковому швидкому
режимі було Верховна Рада була прийнято
закон України про встановлення державних
гарантій В умовах воєнного стану якщо
можна презентацію щоб вона за мною
встигала
було прийнято закон про державні
гарантії і основною метою цього закону
було забезпечити захист всім нашим
учасникам освітнього процесу і щодо
того щоб вони не втратили місця роботи і
місце навчання щоб вони забезпечені були
дистанційною формою навчання якнайбільш
безпечною в тих умовах і
зробити все для того щоб гарантувати
нашому освітянам збереження оплати праці
і отримання студентами
всіх виплат які вони
могли отримати це були соціальні
стипендії академічні стипендії цей закон
було прийнято теж
на початку війни
друге що було прийнято Це був прийнятий
закон який спростив систему зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання
такі було достатньо складний виклик для
нас всіх Ми з коли ми прийняли цей закон
тут навіть така була ситуація що закон
було прийнятий не так не так складно як
потім виконати цей закон на от
посміхається Андрій Олександрович нам
наша була така задача що нам потрібно
було дуже швидко розробити нову систему
яка то що ми пам'ятаєте всі освітяни
зараз дивляться Як довго ми створювали
систему зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання Як довго ми його
вдосконалювали і тут стояв виклик була
задача ж найкоротший час
розробити таку систему яка б замінила
ЗНО І ви яка змогла працювати в умовах
війни яка б змогла забезпечити безпечні
умови складання
[музика]
національного мультиплементного тесту і
ще третій виклик який був забезпечити
можливість складання його для тих наших
студентів які знаходились за кордоном і
ці три задачі потрібно було вирішити
швидко і це було зроблено це було не
просто але ми це зробили Я хочу сказати
що за цей такі дуже короткий термін ми
змогли розробити цілих три типи
незалежного оцінювання перше - це
національне мультипедметний тест друге -
це магістерський тест навчальної
компетентності там магістерський
комплексний тест І зараз нас успішно
триває вже друга сесія спеціальна сесія
національного мультиплексного тесту Я
хочу сказати що явка на основну сесію
склала майже 90% від тих хто
Зареєструвався і це
неймовірний результат який ми навіть не
очікували тому Дякую всім хто був
доручений головне Дякую нашим
абітурієнтам які все-таки складають У
нас в Україні
національний мультиплектний тест
складають вступні творчі іспити там де
не потрібен тест на тих спеціальностях і
роблять це для того вступити в
українські заклади вищої освіти для нас
вони сьогодні одна із основних завдань
для всіх влади зробити так щоб зберегти
українські інтелектуальний потенціал і
надати можливість нашим абітурієнтам
навчатися в українських закладах освіти
і ще хочу сказати що нас виникла одразу
коли Ми зрозуміли що в нас є тимчасово
окуповані території що в нас є території
де зараз активні бойові дії Ми зрозуміли
що нам потрібно не витягувати наших
дітей звідти потрібно теж було
придумувати нові варіанти як зробити і в
нас виникла така ініціатива з тимофією
мелованами яку підтримали одразу
Міністерство освіти попросити звернутися
залучити наші приватні заклади вищої
освіти до вступної кампанії і надати
можливість дітям з тимчасово окупованих
територій які не можуть зараз виїхати з
цих територій Оскільки ми знаємо що нам
зараз складна ситуація надати їм
можливість безкоштовно
навчатися в українських університетах
приватних і дозволити забезпечити
можливість дистанційного вступу
дистанційної освіти безкоштовного
проживання в гуртожитках поки коли ми
потім їх заберемо вирвимо їх з
тимчасового окупованих територій тому що
зараз ми боремося за кожного нашого
абіту я хочу подякувати всім в нас Майже
30 приватних закладів вищої освіти Не
дивлячись на дуже складну фінансову
ситуацію який приватний сьогодні
знаходяться майже 30 закладів освіти
відгукнулися і зараз пролісокну компанію
Я вже декілька відвідувала була в Одесі
міжнародних гуманітарній університет
в Києві зараз ось поїду європейські
університет Міжнародна академія
управління персоналом Всім дякую хто
долучився і дійсно на сьогодні набирають
дітей з Херсонської області Запорізької
області з Харківської області які зараз
не можуть виїхати знаходяться на
тимчасовому території Я вам дуже дякую
це яскравий приклад того як ми всі
допомагаємо
безпосередньо Україні Не дивлячись на те
як би складно нам на сьогодні не було і
працюємо разом
коротко про те які проблеми зараз в нас
є
що можна презентацію
Дякую
перша проблема яку ми всі спостерігаємо
кожного дня Вона тільки на жаль ця
проблема набирає більше обертів це
пошкодження освітньої інфраструктури
На жаль в нас є особливо яскраво
яскравим негативному сенсі приклад - це
Харківська область Харків і Харківська
область Миколаїв та Миколаївська область
коли ми втрачаємо нашу інфраструктуру і
це той виклик з якимось теж зараз
повинні знаходити вихід з цієї ситуації
на жаль ми втрачаємо нашу інфраструктуру
і лабораторії і те що ми будували багато
років така ситуація є і ми будемо цю
проблему вирішувати вирішувати вирішуємо
її вже зараз звичайно ми розуміємо що
нас складна ситуація з фінансуванням
в нас є дефіцит коштів для фінансування
закладів вищої освіти Ну і звичайно ми
маємо ту проблему що в нас на сьогодні я
застаріла система управління фінансовими
закладами вищої освіти Ми її констатуємо
вже декілька років в нас вже
підготовлені і в комітеті і
міністерством розроблені законопроекти
які передбачають зміни до цієї системи і
зараз в умовах війни ця проблема
особливо яскраво перед нами проявилася і
вже зараз ми цю проблему вирішуємо
вирішуємо її достатньо максимально
швидкому темпі тому що часу в нас немає
Отже які варіанти вирішення тих проблем
які звичайно проблем хочу сказати що нас
на багато більше Сьогодні я зараз
розповіла про ті які найбільш глобальні
тому що колеги які далі будуть говорити
вони вже будуть говорити про більш
деталі Я говорю про більш глобальні
проблеми які на сьогодні в нас є ті
варіанти вирішення які вже сьогодні
над якими ми вже працюємо нас чекає
звичайно ми всі розуміємо що в нас буде
нова освітня мережа закладів вищої
освіти внаслідок пошкодження внаслідок
того що ми дещо втратили контингент все
це вплине на те що ми будемо мати нову
освітню мережу ми з вами всі
консультували те що в нас забагато було
закладів вищої освіти в Україні і зараз
в нас буде нова мережа і ми над нею вже
працюємо і причини вже цього я вже
назвала ми всі їх з вами розуміємо
змінюємо будемо змінювати
організаційно-правову форму всіх
університетів тому що така
організаційно-правова форма як бюджетна
установа на сьогодні не дає можливість
повноцінно розвиватися університетом нам
потрібно давати більше фінансової
Свободи мати можливість продукувати
науку результати наукової діяльності
заробляти на цьому і
розширяти можливості закладам освіти для
того щоб вони мали можливість заробляти
кошти самостійно збільшувати кількість
платних послуг освіти які ми можемо
надавати тобто робити все для того щоб
кожен університет ставав такою
структурою яка може не тільки навчати а
й продукувати певну продукцію освітню
наукову заробляти кошти Оскільки
у нас зараз і коштів не вистачить
фінансувати в такому режимі як раніше
заклади
вищої освіти і надавати більше
можливостей 7 університетам щоб
заробляти кошти
безумовно тому що це європейська система
і тільки на фінансування державного ми
далеку не вийдемо будемо продукувати
самі нові послуги заробляти на них Ну
звичайно створення нових механізмів
залучення коштів все це теж над цим
працюємо в нових законопроектах і Бізнес
як повноцінний учасник освітнього
процесу та партнер ззов нас вже багато
університетів на сьогодні працюють тісно
з бізнесом і всі розуміємо що освіта для
освіти нікому не потрібна освіта повинна
працювати для працевлаштування
для підготовки якісних кадрів які потім
можуть знаходити роботу і безпосередньо
бізнес нам потрібно обов'язково залучати
навчальний процес і у формі
консультаційній залучення до
викладацької діяльності і у формі
фінансової допомоги фінансування
лабораторії підтримки науково-технічної
бази все це теж нам потрібно робити на
сьогодні і робити давати фінансові
можливості університетам використовувати
цю
фінансову допомогу яку від бізнесу
можемо отримувати коли якщо дуже коротко
То в мене все ще радять навчився
там очередь
и Хочешь сказати що освіта була є і буде
в Україні і все
Шановні колеги я дуже прошу ми просто
чуємо ваші приватні розмови тому
Зверніть будь ласка зустрічаємося
Шановні колеги Дякую Юля Миколаївна за
вашу чудову презентацію за чудовою
виступи нам надали напрями там де ми
маємо працювати от будемо Завжди
розраховувати на підтримку комітету
Поясніть комітету Міністерства яка є
зараз ну це наскільки мені відомо в
історії України жодного разу ще не було
я вам дякую за це бо ви є драйвером саме
в питаннях вищої освіти і співпраці з
вами і я дуже комфортною і досить
ефективно Шановні колеги перш ніж
передати слово наступному нашому спікеру
Я хотів би звернути вашу увагу на той
ролик який показується на екрані поза
нашому спинами там ви зможете побачити
[музика]
Скажімо так На жаль Ти пошкоджені
будівлі в багатьох містах України що
зробили ці негідники з системою вищої
освіти України Ми впевнені що ми все
відбудуємо але цього їм жодним чином не
вибачимо адже вони Б'ють по самому
чутливому для українців це по їх знаннях
і по їх інноваційному потенціалу і перш
ніж
передати слово наступного учасниках Я
хочу сказати що ми зробимо Зараз трошки
такий формат запросимо до слова Андрія
Петровича Бутенко який нам розповість
про виклики якісь в період воєнного часу
для оцінювання якості і взагалі для
якості вищої освіти в Україні
скрытые науки за його зусилля в
підтримці цього важливого напрямку ми з
вами всі прекрасно розуміємо що дітям
молоді потрібні куміри потрібні
позитивні приклади для того щоб рухатися
розвиватись правильного напрямку
слід сьогодні констатувати На жаль що
добре відомий нам гасла спорт поза
політикою сьогодні не працює і сьогодні
намагання продовжити свою участь у
міжнародному спортивному співтоваристві
спортсменів Білорусі і Росії повністю
суперечать ідеалом олімпійської хартії
якою ми всі керуємо і я дякую всім
[музика]
установам державним керівництво держави
Україна і наша міжнародним партнерам
європейським партнерам за те що вони
роблять це необхідно для того щоб їх
відсторонити від чистого сучасного
олімпійського спорту
мабуть не всі знають що частина наших
всесвітньо відомих спортсменів
призупинили свою спортивну діяльність і
пішли до лав збройних сил України
національної гвардії
серед них є поранені і на жаль Навіть є
загибелі
тому говорити сьогодні ще раз про
важливість спорту про важливість
військово-патріотичного виховання
абсолютно актуальна абсолютно на честь
ми знаходимось у стані війни
збільшується небезпека для не тільки
України а для Європи і для всього світу
все більше активності набирає питання
негайного відновлення повноцінного
процесу національного патріотичного та
військового виховання і підвищення рівня
фізичної і початковою військовою
підготовки нашої мови до призовна
підготовка має бути складовою частиною
визначеною державною системою освіти
вищих професійних технічних
загальноосвітніх навчальних закладів
Отже знання і вміння з
військово-патріотичного фізичного
виховання основ початкової військової
підготовки здобуті молоді дадуть і змогу
швидше і успішніше адаптуватись
в армійському середовищі допоможуть
виробити почуття колективізму допомоги
взаємовиручки поваги до історичної
спадщини а також зміцнити фізично
духовна стати справжніми патріотами
готовими захищати свою вітчизну Я хотів
би зробити наголос на тому коли що
нормативна правова і законодавча база в
тих питаннях які я зараз порушую вона
практично сформована є стратегія
військово-патріотичного виховання
концепція його є створений
державний орган
державного центру
військово-патріотичного виховання з
величезним планом заходів Я думаю що
одним з останніх кроків формування
нормативної бази є прийнятий в першому
читання закон про основні засади
державної політики у сфері утвердження
української національної та
громадянської ідентичності там
повноцінна представлений цей напрямок
про який ми зараз з вами говоримо
Але я думаю що нам всі ці державні акти
треба наповнювати конкретним змістом і
разом із спортивної громадськістю
реалізовувати їх установленому порядку я
хотів би на завершення сказати що тільки
товариство Динамо має в цьому
розпорядження біля двохсот спортивних
споруд 18 база олімпійських підготовки
порядка 15 стрілецьких комплексів
універсальних спортивних залів
майданчиків
в товаристві працюють більше 200
тренерів надзвичайно високої
кваліфікації які готують не тільки
чемпіонів світу олімпійських чемпіонів а
щодня працюють з дітьми
ми запропонували і ми готуємо сьогодні
пропонуємо вам план заходів спільні
програми які я хотів би користуючись
нагодою запропонувати до Міністерства до
зокрема обласних управління освіти щодо
конкретних дій в реалізації цих питань у
нас готові ці документи ми подаємо вам
руку і готові разом зробити все можливе
для того щоб дійсно наші діти
виховались в правильному напрямку були
патріотами були готові будь-яку хвилину
стати на захист своєї вітчизни я дякую
вам за увагу і Сподіваюсь на нашу плідну
подальшу співпрацю Дякую Віктор
Петровичу Дякую вам за вашу пропозицію
ми обов'язково врахуємо адже зараз Ми
формуємо нові компетентності які
стосуються питань які захисту вітчизни і
змінюємо і навчальні програми нам і в
середній школі і будемо змінювати їх і
вищій школі для того наші діти мали
практичні навички знання та вміння для
щодо і розмінування і поводження
вибухонебезпечними предметами і надання
першої медичної до медичної допомоги
тобто тактичної медицини на жаль на жаль
нам треба ці навички і ваша допомога нам
буде дуже потрібна в цьому питанні
[музика]
інвентар ми будемо деталізувати все
необхідне Так що я ще раз дякуємо
дякуємо і хочу передати слово сьогодні
Максиму георгічу Луцькому ректору
національної академії
національна Авіаційна ректор
національного авіаційного університету
перепрошуємо цими георгічні господарю
сьогоднішньої нашої сьогоднішньої
площадки дякую дякую
Юлія Миколаївна Шановні колеги Доброго
дня
враховуючи брак часу буду говорити
максимально коротко
дійсно Війна змінила наше життя змінила
наше життя і це треба визнавати страшно
уявити що ми з вами втрачаємо один
навчальний заклад в день
коли я працював з Віктором петровичем
Київської міської державної
адміністрації головою ми завжди
відвідували всі відкриття навчальних
закладів і для Києва для Києва було
супер Якщо ми відкривали дві школи та 2
дитячих садочка на них А ми сьогодні
втрачаємо один вдень і можна лише уявити
Які кошти будуть потрібні для відбудови
але як правильно начинаєш кажу все
відбудуємо і будемо жити працювати
сьогодні є величезна проблема у вищих
навчальних закладів це
переміщення тимчасово вищий навчальний
заклад окупованої території і хочу
подякувати нашому міністром освіти і
науки
заступника міністра
депутат Юлії Миколаївни що ви відвідуєте
регіони і дивитесь тому що читати новини
і бачити своїми очима це дві різні речі
і
я вважаю це дуже корисним тому що люди
які знаходяться в Харкові в наших
навчальних закладів в Чернігові вони
потребують не тільки підтримки там
навіть фізично приїхати підтримати що це
буде змінено це дуже важливо страшно
дивитись Коли сотні людей
на вулиці готують собі їжу страшно
дивитись на це але це відбувається в
нашому житті відбувається зараз тому
відвідувати
психологічно підтримати людей це дуже
серйозна робота Я вам дуже вдячний мав
можливість теж побути в Харкові і в
Одесі і в Миколаєві і в інших містах Ну
як ректору як господарства мені страшно
дивиться на ті речі
одна проблема переміщенні Друга проблема
- це якщо подивитися Каразіна гуртожитки
нема корпуси розбиті але люди все одно
зранку ідуть на роботу і працюють те
саме відбувається в Миколаєві
Якщо говорити про
нашу університету то звичайно ми більш
підготовленими і цілі гуртожитки і
корпуси Слава Богу поки що
сподіваємося що це так і буде і маємо
писати лише саме тим що навчальним
закладом який перебувають в стані або
окупованих територій або розбом
Якщо говорити про національне оцінювання
університет ми повністю готовимо 22
серпня починаємо навчальний процес 2-34
курс всі викладачі виходять на роботу
але ми забезпечуємо змішану форму це
буде Одна зміна дві зміни в залежності
кількості студентів які уявить бажання
офлайн онлайн ми будемо поважати їх
точку зору і звичайно Будемо робити все
для того щоб допомагати нашим колегам
населення ми
готові і ми Українці Ми унікальна нація
і ми подивимось всі виплати часу які
будуть до нас тому Дякую за те що
прилетити захід і вітаю всіх колег це
буде Україна можна якщо звісно я
прокоментую коротко Максима георгійовичу
я ось такого тільки що важливу річ
сказала сказали Я хочу закцентувати
сформу увагу звернутися до інших можливо
авторів які нас дивляться
зараз дуже складний час і наше основне
завдання розуміти те що ми повинні
забезпечити можливість доступу до вищої
освіти всім нашим студентам і
абітурієнтам де вони не знаходились над
тимчасово окуповані території за
кордоном або на за місцем свого
проживання Ми повинні сьогодні Якби це
не було складно бути максимально
гнучкими тому і дуже цінно те що робити
ви те що роблять більшість переважна
більшість наших університетів
забезпечують можливість студентам
навчатися в тій формі в якій вони мають
сьогодні можливість або навіть бажання
тому що якщо є запит в когось навчатися
дистанційно він повинен його отримати
якщо є запит навчатися офлайн він
повинен його отримати
Таким чином ми зберемо ми збережемо наші
тотальний потенціал оскільки Якщо ми
будемо це складно Я розумію дуже складно
дуже але це те що ми повинні робити
сьогодні для майбутнього нашої країни це
не просто красиві слова кожен студент -
це наше майбутнє і якщо в когось не буде
можливості отримати доступ не буде
дистанційки або не буде офлайну ми
будемо втрачати звичайно мова йде тільки
про ті ситуації де це дозволяє там де
офлайн це не дозволяє безпекова ситуація
тому Дякую всім тим
заклад на вищої освіти хто попрацював
працює зараз і
надаємо можливість студентам навчатися в
тій формі яку вони обирають і ми повинні
бути готові до того що вони будуть
змінювати свої в них буде змінюватися
ситуація Хтось зараз веде на офлайн
потім піде на дистанцію Та ж сама
ситуація в наших школах Да так воно буде
І ми повинні бути до цього готовими і
Дякую всім тим хто працює сьогодні в
цьому напрямку
Дякую Юлія Миколаївна Шановні колеги
Дякую всім за чудові виступи ми вже
працюємо протягом години відповідно в
нашому чаті є велика кількість запитань
але не лише запитань а пропозиції які ми
обов'язково відпрацюємо там є пропозиції
до зміни до деяких постанов Кабінету
Міністрів України
Я думаю що можна поступити Таким чином
ми будемо офіційно брати ці питання Та
ці пропозиції як запит на публічну
інформацію ми разом з колегами в
міністерстві їх опрацюємо і найближчий
ні відповідно до чинного законодавства
сім надамо ґрунтовно відповідь щодо того
тієї чи іншої проблеми тієї чи іншої
проблематики або тієї чи іншої
пропозиції
Шановні колеги Дякую що вам кожному з
вас за те що взяли участь в
сьогоднішньої панелі Я хотів би ще в
першу чергу подякувати вищому
політичному керівництву держави за їх
мужність за те що вони роблять для
України і окремо хочу подякувати всім
освітянам нашим
які вистояли які показали свою мужність
які показали що сфера освіти України є
сталою вона є інноваційною і сфера
освіти України забезпечить
функціонування Ну вже після збройних сил
На жаль але зможе забезпечити
функціонування подальших України як
держави як на і українцям як нація якщо
можна Якщо ви хочете сказати ще декілька
слів до наших колег то запрошую до слова
дякую
Так я дуже коротко користуюся такою
можливістю що ми тут зараз з вами
об'єднані на такому заході освітньому і
дійсно продовження слів Андрій
Олександровича сказати що
зараз збройні сили з зброєю в руках за
ціною своїх життів захищають нас для
того щоб ми тут з вами могли працювати в
нас у кожного свій фронт і
освітяни українські наші всі це
вами пишається весь світ я була великою
кількістю різних відряджень і всі завжди
казали мені про те що ми не можемо
зрозуміти як система освіти Невже
система освіти не зупинилася Невже хоча
б тимчасово ніхто не вірив за кордоном
що таке може бути що система освіти буде
працювати під час такої відкритої
агресії коли йдуть ракетні обстріли коли
гинуть люди але все одно освіта працює
Тому
нас дійсно дуже мужня така сфера я дякую
кожному з вас хочу сказати що війна
закінчиться закінчиться скоро ми
вистоємо всі і допомагаємо один одному
підтримуємо один одному тому що що саме
в єдності наша сила Дякую Андрій
Петрович Дякую колеги я б хотів дуже
коротко подякувати людям які мали
ймовірно дивляться цей ефір Але
сподіваюсь що їм хтось передасть це всім
хлопцям і дівчатам які зараз лавах
збройних сил національної гвардії
Добровольський батальйонах в силах
турборони життям яких
змушена жертвувати українська нація для
того щоб могли розвиватися мирні
напрямки життя про це вже скажу пане
Андрія пані Юлія Але мені здається про
це не потрібно наголошувати раз за разом
Дякуємо всім Дякуємо за те що ви даєте
нам можливість працювати Дякуйте що з
кожної хвилини наближаєте спільну нашу
перемогу дякую вам
Дякую Андрій Петрович
шановні друзі
Шановні колеги давайте ще трошки
хвилиночку
[музика]
Я хотів би ще додати два слова з приводу
того що багато чого залежить саме Від
нас
в четвер минуле Я був на Чернігівщині і
відвідав школу однушку звичайно школа
там працює 47 вчителів і там 5-7
чоловіків які там займаються
господарчими питаннями такою красивою
територією
з бомбосховищем з квітами
купили А все Робимо своїми руками тому
ми як Флеш як хоче щоб ми можемо назвати
ми теж будемо своїм колективом наводити
власну територію і це все в наших силах
це все в наших силах Головне бажання
Шановні колеги
хотів би поставити вам до нас доєднався
Міністр освіти і науки України Сергій
Миколайович шкар
Доброго дня дорогі сміття не дорогі
колеги
де в мене це вже сьогодні третя локація
ради вітати всіх Нагадую що у нас
сьогодні
запущений флешмоб повертаємось на
навчання
в принципі
Бажаю всім щоб цей був перший і останній
початок нового навчального року під час
війни всім нам Миру всім нам Перемоги
всім нам безпечного навчання
адже на сьогодні
вища освіта вона в пріоритеті
вища освіта випускає в економіку
фахівців
на яких сьогодні вся Україна
орієнтується
щодо процесу майбутнього відновлення
вища освіта сьогодні як Флагман показує
нам всім
які пріоритет спеціальностей майбутнього
мають обрати
українці для того щоб відновити цю
державу
вища освіта сьогодні
надає всі можливості
дітям навіть яким
абітурієнтам
першокурсникам всім тим хто навіть
знаходиться поза межами вимушений був
знаходитись поза межами території
України але виявив бажання
майже в 40 містах країн усього світу
здати національний мультиплектний тест і
вступити до закладів вищої освіти
України ми очікуємо
додатковий спеціальну сесію ми проводимо
сьогодні додаткову і буде ще в нас
спеціальна сесія по
вступу до магістратури ми активно
готуємось спільно з національним
агентством з питань якості освіти щодо
підтримки тих професійних провідних
програм які
започатковані як професії майбутнього як
спеціальності майбутнього для закладів
вищої освіти України
ми активно з провідними університетами
вчора провели спілку ректорів на якій
прийняті надважливіші рішення які тільки
покращать Нашу З вами освіту разом з
комітетом Верховної Ради з питань освіти
науки та інновації разом з під комітетом
вищої освіти з Юрієм Миколаївною
сьогодні вже Від міністерства освіти і
науки
надісланий лист до центральної та інших
центральних органів виконавчої влади
щодо перетину кордонів студентами
на сьогодні робиться ціла низка заходів
які дозволять нам з вами сформувати
вищу освіту таку яку ми прагнемо для
достойного розвитку нашої держави
повертаємось до навчання навчання в
безпечних умовах і сьогодні більшість
закладів вищої освіти автономні але
спроможні забезпечити
освітній процес принаймні змішаному
навчанні там де буде відбуватися
соціалізація Де студенти зможуть
спілкуватися вільно один з одним Де
студенти відновлять професійне
спілкування з професорами і доцентами де
буде професійний обмін думками навіть
між колегами що теж є досить досить
таким цінним в умовах постковідної і
воєнної воєнної доби Дякую всім Бажаю
успіхів бажаю плідної роботи на нашій
серпневій конференції і найкраще
побажання всім повертаємось до навчання
Дякуємо Сергій Миколайовичу дуже рада що
ви до нас приєдналися З повагою
шановні друзі Шановні колеги наразі
будемо закінчувати нашу секцію Дякую
всім хто підключився Дякую всім хто взяв
участь в обговоренні де задав нам
питання та надав свої пропозиції
Гарного вам всім дня і повертаємося до
навчання